Amazon's upcoming Lord of the Rings
prequel is set to take place in
middle-earth Second Age thousands of
years before the movies take place but
just what does that mean for the series
here are a few things that fans want to
see in Amazon's Lord of the Rings
prequel one of the most tantalizing
facets of middle-earth second age is the
constant presence of the stories most
iconic villain
Sauron Sauron is actually corrupted my
heir a kind of angelic spirit that
existed long before the beginning of
time itself early on in the history of
middle-earth Sauron then known as Myron
was lured to the dark side by the first
Dark Lord Morgoth during morgoth's rain
on middle-earth Sauron acted as his
chief lieutenant at the end of the first
stage however Morgoth was defeated and
banished from the world after this hour
on fled and hid for several centuries
it wasn't until around 500 years later
that sour on spirit began to stir first
Sauron established his new stronghold on
middle-earth by that point there were
still many nations of men far away in
the east and south that had been
corrupted by Morgoth back in the day
hoping to utilize this power sour and
chooses more doors his new stomping
ground and work soon began on the Dark
Tower about a door considering how
important Mordor is to the Lord of the
Rings trilogy story it's pretty much a
dead certainty that the region will make
an appearance in Amazon's new series 1
elements of Sauron story that's going to
be fascinating to see is how he has
portrayed earlier on in the second Age
that's because Sauron wasn't always sour
on the great and terrible sure the Dark
Lord is most well known for being the
terrifying specter of death and
destruction that appears throughout the
Hobbit and Lord of the Rings movies but
that isn't what Sauron looks like for
most of the Second Age not by a long
shot
in fact when Sauron first appears on the
scene he takes on the appearance of a
beautiful elf named onit are the Lord of
gifts and this isn't just a flash in the
pan disguise our own uses to trick the
other elves he actually keeps up with
his onit our masquerade for 400 years so
it's quite clear that when Sauron
appears in the Amazon series he's
probably not going to look like how
you'd expect him to ok so this bit isn't
too hard everyone knows what the One
Ring is it's the fancy piece of jewelry
that whispers at its owners turns him
invisible and subtly tries to corrupt
them to do evil deeds it plays a key
role in The Hobbit and it's a central
focus of the entire Lord of the Rings
trilogy
the rain and the Dark Lord Frodo he must
never find it but where did the ring
come from well long before the events of
the hobbits or the Lord of the Rings
took place and long before Smeagol got
his hands on it the ring was forged in
Mordor by the Dark Lord Sauron put in a
long story short Sauron crafted the ring
in order to try to gain control over the
elves and although his plan backfired
the forging of the One Ring is still a
momentous event in middle-earth history
as a massive portion of sauron's power
was poured into that little gold ring
but how is this relevant to Amazon's
Lord of the Ring series
well guess when the One Ring was forged
yeah that's right slap bang in the
middle of the world's second Age so how
did the One Ring actually work how was
Sauron hoping to control the people of
middle-earth through a tiny little
trinket here's how it started during the
Second Age Sauron actually spent a good
chunk of his time helping the elves
forge their own rings of power disguised
as an elf name on ATAR the Dark Lord
hooked up with a group of particularly
talented elvish craftsmen who were then
led by an elf named Kelly Bryn born
under an Attar's guidance Kelly Bryn
Moore and his elves forged 16 rings then
using what they had learned from the
disguised Dark Lord they forged for
themselves three greater rings of power
vilya Narnia and Nanyang once the great
elves of middle-earth were suitably
bejeweled Sauron returned to Mordor to
forge the One Ring into which he poured
a great deal of his own strength after
the ring was finished he tried to use it
to exert his will over all the other
rings of power unfortunately for him
Sauron was unable to control those other
rings and as soon as he put on the One
Ring the elves realized that they had
been betrayed in rage the Dark Lord
launched an attack on the elves
beginning what's known as the War of the
elves and sour on over the course of
this war Kelly Bryn Boras killed all but
the three rings are reclaimed by Sauron
and more adores armies overrun
practically every corner of middle-earth
the entire story is dripping with drama
and could easily take up a season or
more of Amazon's news show most of the
Lord of the Rings centers around
sarang's attempt to gain control of
middle-earth by force even his pursuit
to the One Ring is centered around the
Rings ability to dominate the will of
others that accelerates his ambitious
conquests but the War of the ring wasn't
sarang's first taste of conquest and
during the main trilogy the Dark Lord is
simply trying to regain what he
controlled during the second age after
Sal runs attempt to conquer the elves
via the One Ring failed he gathered an
army of orcs trolls and other evil
creatures and waged war against the
elvish kingdoms he mostly succeeded too
and drove the elves back against the
western coasts just before he gained
complete victory though a powerful race
of men known as the númenóreans showed
up and saved their elvish allies from
total annihilation
while he didn't quite succeed in
annihilating his enemies once the war
was finished sour uncontrolled
practically all of middle-earth as is
reflected in his self-appointed title
lord of the earth it's at this point
that he became widely known as the Dark
Lord he ruled by force and fear and
dominated the realms of men that lived
in the eastern and southern regions of
the continent in fact they soon came to
look at him as both a lord and a God
until navels affair a dream from the
south listeners from the coast
these times are known as the black years
and it should go without saying that
they'd be a fascinating setting for a
portion of the show story while a lot of
interesting stuff goes on during the
black years there's one particular
aspect of that era that is really worth
exploring
after Sauron defeated Kellum brim bore
and seized most of the rings of power he
began to distribute them to various
other people that he wanted to dominate
he gave some to the Dwarven Lords but
they were stubborn and uncooperative to
saurons will and simply became obsessed
with their treasure hoards but men
turned out quite easy to control
Sauron gave out nine rings through a
group of men who became rich and
powerful Kings Warriors and sorcerers on
top of that they also appeared to
receive the gift of unending life
unfortunately what didn't work on the
elves worked all too easily on men
before long they began to feel the
corrupting power of their rings and
their intimate connection with the
dominant One Ring
over time these nine men became
permanently invisible living in a shadow
realm in which only the Dark Lord could
see them like the Living Dead they
persisted in an unending life in which
they only existed to serve their master
if this all sounds familiar it's because
you've seen these demonic servants
before they are the nazgûl the Black
Riders that chased Frodo and his friends
out of the Shire and across middle-earth
the Second Age is basically an origin
story for these terrifying villains and
be a real shame not to include them in
the upcoming series the second age isn't
just the cradle of middle-earth siebel
though it's also the time in which some
of the world's most important elvish
settlements were established right from
the get-go literally in year one of the
Second Age the elvish dwelling of meet
wand was settled on the northwestern
shores of middle-earth this Harbor is
the continents primary connection to the
otherworldly blessed realm of Alma in
practice meatwad provides the elves with
an opportunity to escape and join their
kindred in the West should they want to
leave middle-earth for good the harbour
is also known as the Grey Havens and
makes an appearance at the very end of
The Return of the King the other elvish
town worthy of notes is Rivendell a
stronghold that plays a key role in both
the Hobbit and The Lord of the Rings
stories was initially founded partway
through the Second Age Elrond founded
Rivendell as a refuge for his elves
after he retreated from sour Ahn's
armies during the War of the elves and
Sauron considering its importance
throughout middle-earth history it would
be a fine treat for fans to glimpse an
earlier inception of this powerful
elvish settlement you are very welcome
to stay if that is HUGE
few faces are as familiar to Lord of the
Rings fans as Galadriel the official
leader is instrumental in helping the
fellowship during the Lord of the Rings
and she gets in on the action and Peter
Jackson's adaptation of The Hobbit - but
fans will know that by that point in the
story Galadriel has had a hand in Middle
Earth's fate for thousands of years by
the beginning of the Second Age
Galadriel had already married her
husband Kelly born and the elvish couple
spent most of the Age slowly moving
around middle-earth wherever they went
they usually ended up helping to lead
some group of wandering elves or another
they also spent time with Kelly primp or
visited Rivendell and got caught up in
elvish politics from time to time it was
also around this point that glad real
was given Nanyang one of the three elven
rings akela brim boar hid from Sauron
she also gave birth to her daughter
Calabria who went on to become the wife
of Elrond and the mother of arwen
needless to say it wouldn't be
surprising if at some point Galadriel or
Kelly Bourne made an appearance or two
on the show
Gandalf's duel against the Balrog and
the Fellowship of the Ring is one of the
stories most iconic moments that
confrontation takes place in the dusty
remains of Moria but as you'd expect
there was a time at which Moria was
populated if you whine thanks back to
the Second Age this Kingdom known as
cause of doom had already been around a
very long time and it's still filled
with dwarves that are alive and well
roaring fires filled tough abode and
when the elves led by Kellan Brin more
settled down in the next-door region of
Arabian they struck up a harmonious
friendship with their dwarfing neighbors
something that's all too rare in
Tolkien's mythology overlooking their
racial prejudices the Smith craft
focused elves of Kellum brim borne the
dwarves of Casas doom enjoyed a fabulous
trading partnership throughout the first
half of the second age however this came
to an abrupt end when Sauron attacked
Kellan prim poorest people and the tours
were forced to shut their gate they
didn't do much after this until the very
end of the Second Age when they came
back out to help in the war of the last
Alliance by the time of the Lord of the
Rings few relics remain from the
alliance between the elves of Aragon and
the dwarves of Casa doom one of them
however could make a surprising cameo
during Amazon's upcoming series the
doors of durin
at its height Casa doom stretched from
one side of the Misty Mountains to the
other and on the western side of the
mountain range it had one primary
entrance known
the doors of durin fans of the Peter
Jackson films will recognize these
glowing doors from one of the fellowship
the rings most famous scenes granted the
Fellowship's encounter with the doors
ends pretty badly but in the second age
the Gateway was a much happier place and
the doors themselves are usually left
open with elves and dwarves passing
through with impunity the gates
themselves were designed and built
through an extremely rare cooperative
effort between the ring forger Kellum
bream bore and the Dwarven craftsmen
narvi both of whom were recognized as
the two greatest artisans at the age
seeing these gates being built and
ultimately sealed shut would be a
welcome nod to the events of the Lord of
the Rings one of the most important
facets of Amazon's Lord of the Rings
prequel can be found off the mainland of
middle-earth out in the Western seas
here you'll find one of the iconic
geographic locations of the Second Age
the island of númenor also known as
weston s this island ends up playing a
critical role in the later events of the
age as the second age kicks off though
the landmass doesn't yet exist the first
age ended with the catastrophic war of
Wrath which led to a large chunk of
Western middle-earth being sunk beneath
the ocean and the aftermath of this
cataclysmic event the angelic stewards
of the earth known as the Valar raised
up a star-shaped island continent they
also placed it far enough away from the
shores of middle-earth to keep its
inhabitants safe from the evils of the
mainland the Valar blessed the island
themselves making an extremely fertile
and offered it as a land of refuge to
the men who fought on their side during
the war of Wrath the island is
technically called on door the land of
gift but it ultimately becomes known as
Numenor named after the people that
dwell there the group of men that
ultimately found the island of númenor
is led by a guy named el ros who happens
to be el Ron's brother due to some
complicated family history the brothers
and their children are given the option
to live as either mortal men or as
immortal elves while Elrond chooses the
latter el Rose becomes a mortal King
although he still goes on to live for
almost 500 years the line of Kings that
comes from El Rose ultimately leads to
none other than Aragorn himself and it
would be a cool through-line to follow
in the prime series a descendant of
númenor
blessed with long life it was said that
your race had passed into legend there
are few of us left it was only the
timely intervention of the númenóreans
that put a stop to saurons onslaught
against the elves of middle-earth now on
the back foot and facing defeat the Dark
Lord willingly surrendered to the
númenórean armies who took him back to
their island as a prisoner
what's our on arrived in númenor however
it didn't take long for him to begin
working his charm over time Sauron
weaseled his way up from prisoner status
to that of an advisor to the númenórean
Kings the last of whom was r4 as on one
of the second ages most important
players during his time on the island
Souren set up a cult and convinced the
númenóreans to worship Morgoth as their
God just for kicks he also threw in a
little human sacrifice too but his
greatest victory came when he convinced
r4 is on to attack the bow on themselves
in a foolish attempt to claim their
immortality from them just as Sauron had
planned it the invasion backfired and
our prayer is on and his army were
ruthlessly destroyed but here's what's
our on didn't see coming
startled by the númenórean invasion of
their land the Valar appealed to arrow
in Avatar the of nipa 10-count of the
universe and asked for help you know
Vitara agreed and decided to intervene
something that only ever happened a
handful of times during Middle Earth's
history in ovet are sunk Numenor beneath
the ocean turned the flat world into a
round planet and separated Valinor from
middle-earth forever
only a few númenóreans who had been
faithful to the Valar escaped back to
their colonies on middle-earth
Sauron meanwhile had a spirit torn from
his physical body and fled back to
middle-earth himself it's a heck of a
story and there's pretty much no chance
it won't make up a significant part of
Amazon's Lord of the Ring series after
Numenor sinks beneath the waves the
narrative of the second age shifts back
to the mainland
sour and having lost this physical form
in the chaos fled back to Mordor where
he slowly began to rebuild his power in
the meantime the few surviving
númenóreans also arrived on the mainland
the refugees set about building a new
light for themselves and in the process
they settled two kingdoms each of which
would become vital to the fate of
middle-earth Gondor and Arnor it was
these two nations that began to build
and establish a number of landmarks that
Lord of the Ring spans should recognize
pretty easily
for instance they built the Tower of
Orthanc which the wizard Sauer
eventually uses as its headquarters they
also built the White City of Minas
Tirith although initially Minas Tirith
is little more than a guard tower for a
larger city the capital of Gondor at
this time was oz Gilliam which is the
ruined city visited by fire Emir and his
Hobbit captives at the end of the film
version of the two towers the númenórean
refugees also brought with them the
scene stones at Saruman and Denethor
would use centuries later as well as the
white tree at ministy resummoned here's
hoping Amazon Studios capitalizes on all
these connections to the Peter Jackson
films seeing that their enemy followed
them back to middle-earth the
númenóreans joined with the elves and
dwarves and founded the last Alliance
they took the fight to sour on himself
laying siege to Mordor and fighting the
deadly Battle of dagger lad in the
process eventually the last Alliance
defeated Sauron and routed his armies
from Mordor over the ensuing years the
battlefield that dagger lad slowly
became the swampland known as the Dead
Marshes a terrifying land haunted by the
spirits of the soldiers who fell during
the battle now the war of the last
Alliance and its long lasting effects on
middle-earth have been well portrayed in
Peter Jackson's film trilogy but with
their new series Amazon has a chance to
tell the whole story from its dramatic
beginning to its tragic end check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you